CEO max for Mississippi gang bro Jocko
what was the light hunt for the first
time with John Dudley Tamara Haynes Joe
Rogan Andy stone yeah man just got back
from a hunt up in northern Utah al hunt
and I mean you couldn't really ask for a
better crew of people as you heard he
just rattled off yeah I don't know mr.
Dudley but Haynes is very intense he
loves to hunt you know
yup Minh Dudley's the same way and then
Rogan he loves to hunt and then Andy
Stumpf loves to hunt as well it was my
first time going bow hunting and yeah it
was awesome it was just awesome from the
whole experience was awesome how nice
was the place you guys went was it a
nice place it was a nice place and
that's that's another thing so just to
clarify and people there's no there's
like you know how in different parts of
the world different things in the world
there's like a different there's like a
little subculture in there right yeah so
like you're a comedian and I'm sure
there's people that are like well you
know you got such good deal cuz you got
to this thing and people look down on
these so there's all that stuff I don't
really know too much about it but you
know we got I got the luck and the
blessing of going on a really awesome
hunt okay it's something called private
land right which means not everyone can
go hunt there so there's more animals in
there is if you do something called a
public hunt right so public hunt is like
you're out there and anybody can hunt
there right maybe there's an animal
maybe there's not say there's somebody
on drugs maybe somebody's yeah man yeah
so you might go out four or five eight
ten days you might not even see
unanimity animal that you're hunting for
so I got really lucky really blessed to
to be tied in with this group and and go
out there and the hunt was awesome the
whole experience was awesome there's
something very primal right about going
for going hunting kind of like for me
it's like jiu-jitsu I would say there's
something primal about doing jiu-jitsu
right like you're fighting you know when
you were a little kid and you you and
your friends will just get sticks and
and put on helmets and just go to
more with each other right I mean that's
what we used to do and that's what kid
that's what blue boys do that right
right so there's something primal and
instinctive about just war right
same thing with hunting so you're out
you're stalking you're sneaking around
it has a lot of correlations to my old
job being in the Navy where you're
you're trying to be quiet they're
setting up tactics you're trying to
maneuver on these animals
yeah just like you'd be maneuver on the
enemy you got a raccoon under a
spotlight you like tell us what you have
a recycling bin yeah so that was awesome
and you know going up there it was
really nice for me because I'm very busy
all the time I've always got stuff going
on and we got out there and like the
internet didn't even it worked like
there was one little hill you could go
over we'd get a internet for for three
minutes but I just because of that I
just said you know I'm just gonna shut
this thing off so it's really nice for
me to be up there and and then you have
one mission you know and that's what's
cool about that's one of the best things
about my old job you got one mission Wow
you go on deployment you pack up your
bags you leave the world behind and you
have one mission and that is to close
with and destroy the enemy take care of
your guys that's what you're doing so
that's what this that's what that's my
first experience of hunting was okay my
I'm disconnected from the outer world
and I have one mission so it was awesome
was it interesting cuz those are some
big personality I mean those are like a
big you know that's a unique group they
go away oh yeah it's a it's the thing is
I mean all that all those guys are just
great guys yeah you know I've known I've
known Joe Rogan for a while and people
oh yeah I'm sure people ask you what's
he really I hear what's he really yeah
it's like he's like just exactly what
you see is what you get yeah he's super
nice guy the same thing with I mean
Dudley has invested personally in like
he wanted me to get in hunting yeah gave
me a bone again this is where it sounds
crazy that I could be so lucky in my
life that one of the best archery hunter
in the world would say hey I want you to
get an archer here's a bow let me teach
you
campaigns you know campaigns same thing
he was super cool
debriefing me on stuff and then my buddy
Andy Stumpf which you know Andy and I we
worked together a little bit in the SEAL
Teams but you know I just being out
there with one other SEAL
we have we just have a connection that
you know I you know you can only have
with that Brotherhood so hey man it was
just it was awesome
I look to doing it again and for me you
know you talked about getting in this
new stuff for me it was totally new I
never shot a bow and arrow before and
and then I had the opportunity to to
train and then go out and do it so yeah
it was awesome I appreciate I appreciate
everyone that I just mentioned in that
group yeah just great guys was the
experience where you um when you're so
when you're getting directions like on
something you've never done
how is that for you like coming from a
place where it's like you know you were
you know you're used to having a good
knowledge base of what's going on in
your field do you find yourself to be a
pretty good student do you find yourself
having a tough time being us I'm I'm all
ears man yeah no problem I have no
problem at all saying look I have no
idea it's you know tell me what to do
tell me what to do from the get-go
there's no problem at all with that
how'd you find the Bohanon was it pretty
tricky or did you find it was yeah no
it's definitely tricky
it's definitely tricky how long can you
shoot a detoxes you just [ __ ] uncle
Rico in that [ __ ] over the mouth yeah
it'd be like you know are like way up in
you know really good on a cube has been
an Anytime Fitness for a couple hundred
years firing that thing obviously the
better the better you are the further
range you can go you know so but I would
say the average normal hunter is
probably trying to go 50 something
meters you know something like that is
around you know that's that's that's me
well yeah there's try out trying to get
to that's a little video of me trying to
get tuned up before I and did you find
like did you start to notice that you
lost is it a really fine line between
like how accurate you can be and the
amount of strength you're using and
stuff like that or it's not really a
strength thing it's it's technique you
know so this you can't like just say
anything man
just like anything
jiu-jitsu is not about strength right
that's it's perfectly have you ever been
rock climbing before oh yeah like rock
climbing is so much technique so much
and and you think oh you know cuz I can
do like like Frances I can do a lot of
pull-ups I do a lot of pull-ups I could
see that and you think oh you know you
can just grab on the rocks and climb no
no no there's so much technique involved
that you have to learn the technique
just like basketball just like playing
guitar you have to practice you have to
learn the technique and that's the same
thing with archery and then you just
have to do it over and over again like
shooting a gun you got to do it over and
over again you got to keep those reps in
did you find that as though as the week
progressed this time you guys were out
there that it got easier for you and did
you find you well we weren't shooting a
bunch we were patrolling through the
woods you know and that was cool again I
was out with John Dudley who's a master
hunter I'm just and it's it's awesome
cuz you're on patrol and I keep calling
it on patrol but yeah I suppose it's
called we were hunting and we're walking
but for me my mind I was on patrol oh
hey you know so it was good what's that
oh you're like oh that Bisons from China
like a [ __ ] shoot yeah yeah dude
imagine sneaking a jinglebell out there
with you that would ruin everybody five
you'd have to be real quiet yeah yeah no
we weren't bring your jingle bells out
there even one will shake the world up
on a hunt done be careful that yeah did
you enjoy that clip well you really
would have enjoyed it if he was watching
on a TCL TV TCL is America's fastest
growing TV brand it's so fast it's the
Carl Lewis of television brands it's
that Florence Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com